and welcome to co plane IPO one and
we've got some pruning Kings Indian
probably and no he had this Bishop g4
it's all a bad line I think like it's
it's an offbeat way of playing some with
the Kings Indian flavor but still a
little bit different so kind of
interesting what's what about this yeah
interesting a bishop you three you will
play Knight f5 which is coming anyway
hmm ok let's clarify this situation here
interesting I need to play b3 at some
points as my I'm covering the two now ok
got that covered so quite interesting a
black has an active position with its
pieces my long-term plan is to play
against this epon on that have opened
foul but this is something that is
really larger it to won't materialize
very quickly huh funny it's a funny move
ok check
hmm I guess so
the ideal scenario would be to play
something like Bishop e3 to deform and
then play F form
come on don't drill when I'm playing I
absolutely hate it drilling okay this
looks fine and now I'm able to stop b5
and some f4 it's a looming even though
I've form okay so he allows me to play
that trade without the f porn moving
which is nice okay where do I put the
Queen here I want to double on the
e-file where do I put the Queen may be
here b5 is quite safely under cover
rookie three in the other look to e1 is
a good setup yeah night see 50 maybe I
should put the knight on d4 this is but
if I go back he will play be five hmm I
really like him
okay i also have the H porn push or
nights if I them thinking of just
playing roop to be one okay it's going
h5 mediately so I can put the Knight to
g5 here not sure if it helps much
he still has 95 mm-hmm doesn't play it
surprising
okay so mmm a fine is probably not a
great idea I think Queen wants to come
to you for maybe now I can just take it
take it seven that's nonsense so how to
how to do how to make some progress here
it's not easy it looks quite nice but
there is no clear way forward
acumen should go to d4 actually this
would be helpful okay let's go here
putting it into into this diagonal just
make some sense let's go from here it's
a five mo for probably looks you five I
cannot regroup my nightie in this
position that's kind of the problem I
don't have them clear way forward here
time morning not sure that this is
actually helping me but I don't want to
sit and wait
okay I'm taking this
yeah two loops on the 7th should be
pretty good lad resigned and that it
wasn't necessary I mean this is a
position where white can press forever
but it's not something that like
necessarily has to use I try to make
those small improving moves and then we
are now decided to get push 45 I think
this is correct I mean it freezes blacks
queenside and yeah how the engine gives
night a form as an interesting move oh
yes that one cookie ate him because this
is an assassin robe a perpetual okay
yeah why I played it like that probably
intakes b6 is a little bit better i
think here yeah that looks if I probably
was just really just a blunder there was
no idea behind it 97 should be played
when still white is pressing because of
the space but it's not clear that it
really Nets me much I would it takes a
long time to make something happen him I
would need to bring the King over here
and before and so it takes ages so
probably it's nothing very substantial
yeah it's interesting to note that this
is a sorry this is a standard position
type which is always a little bit better
for white due to the pressure on d file
even though it is very safe it's very
solid for black and so I was a bit
surprised that he so willingly went into
that also here the shattering I think
this is this actually helped me a little
bit
but ultimately the only real thing the
real estate was the blend of the
exchange I think yes so quite decent
chances to hold the position if he
doesn't give me the exchanges like that
okay hope you enjoyed the game thanks
for watching